oh if you're under 18 get the [__] out
of you little [__] uncle Joey's
coming to town but this ain't no [__]
PG show your little [__] let's get this
[__] party started get rid of these
bad spirits in the [__] room you
don't say that's the most important
thing when you get someplace you gotta
get rid of bad I speak those small holes
to you tomorrow
take my hand darling
come with me
look at that [__] that's that's a
cloud like Hurricane Maria what what are
you [__] crazy or what
strap on your seat belts it's gonna be
one of those crazy nights [__] I
can feel it right now
[Music]
the stars are back we got some monster
cookies we got some [__] Pablo
Escobar
we got everything tonight so you better
be ready [__] you put a great
Grandpa's [__] medicine cabinet he's
got something in there for shingles you
take one of those shingle pills with a
couple beers forget about it you'll have
more red spots than [__] Lee Matassa
you take some of that shingle medication
and you may sit a couple cocktails and
the shot of Jack you'll be scratching
all [__] night long but you'll be all
[__] up uncle Joey here September
[__] 25th you hear you're queer you
follow me if you're kneeling down you're
sucking dick get your [__] together
troubles coming to your house what the
[__] Korean people missiles airplanes
hurricanes Mexicans on the buildings
when does it end when does it end
[__] tonight you got your uncle
Joey here to take your mind off the
[__] food salute see I'm saying it's
sukima meantime but uncle Joey
go get your girlfriends I'm gonna brush
your teeth and pick the [__] meat out
of your [__] teeth you nasty [__]
sucking dick would meet your teeth with
type of woman to you I would never yes
or with a missing tooth you know I'm
saying don't suck my dick with meat in
your teeth anyway we want our [__] we
were talking about that for me it's time
for a [__] bong salute to loops are
you ready to go
Don telethon it's captain [__] chaos
coming into your living room [__]
oh [__] just when you thought you were
safe
oh if a plane was going down and you're
going down that little thing came out of
the sky and you better blow oxygen you
better pray to God that some of this
star [__] smoke yet I'm saying look
at these things
he's a blood Stars he's a Russian Shauna
Shauna Shauna stylist
oh wait [__] around tonight you know
saying we're starting off with 12 we're
just going deep tonight Lee fell asleep
last night there you go start with them
[Music]
you got two more three more coming it's
that type of night tonight we'd doubles
we're eating tails where you never think
you're the same and I suggest you do the
same if grandpa got no single medication
your great grandma's got something that
cabinet something for [__] tall or
something I'm saying what [__]
tremendous these are blood stars we're
gonna go deep tonight the best part of
it you're here don't forget if you want
to see the devil on a weekly basis the
stars of death here you go you mix this
with single medication and see what
happens till you get spots and you'll
see spots that's two different [__]
worlds you ain't ready for that yet you
gotta go to bunk at school to get ready
for that [__] situation 1-800 bong
hit early registration listen no
financial variable whatever available if
you ain't got cash you gotta suck dick
and roll joints like a [__] passes
over here boom there you go we're
[__] around joint rolling school is
in progress right now anyway I hope
you're having a good time it's gonna be
a good [__] week you know why cuz
you're prepared [__] if you're
not prepared you better get [__]
prepared
goals push-ups the whole [__] day
please over here choking the debt you
don't know what's coming we got a
special thing coming today we don't like
mushrooms on my friend grinded them down
and mix them with chocolate like the
last time we likes those issues little
mouse who gives a [__]
listen you've eaten [__] black chicks
[__] the same difference
cow should some of these vaginas the
same [__] somebody's ass oh who gives
a [__] you're licking unknown territory
it's always gonna be bad but you take
your chances you Listerine your thumb
and you move on and I'm saying who gives
a [__] about little cows you like your
mouth you never ain't nobody's ass on
that little piece of [__] on the tip but
did you stop no you ate that ass and you
spit that see that lettuce I eat the
watermelon you don't say that's it no
big [__] deal here if you don't need
a [__] just when you thought it was a
[__] that hold on ladies gotta get
across me the [__] gone through me
idiot double gonzo and he like that I've
got sluggers listen seven o'clock at
night 2:00 in the morning I'm dropping
knowledge to more [__] situations
understand me but you said it best
you saved my pimp it's time for a
[__] bong it so raise your [__]
glasses a little bong hit for [__]
Puerto Ricans that they put it back
together
that's a beautiful island with beautiful
[__] people if there'd be no Puerto
Ricans there'd be no pickpocket [__] I'm
saying we meet Porto Ricans so donate
what you can
it all helps out it's a bit of tough
[__] year everybody got donate Sonny
but listen what's the sense of having $3
if you can't help somebody Illinois get
the 37 on it das said anyway let's do a
bong hit we'll talk about sadness later
on right now it's about the good [__]
what we're gonna do and how we're gonna
do it now we're gonna make it
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about right
there if you're thinking a kick in the
mule that's kicking it and punching it
ahead at the same [__] time you ever
kick a mule punching that at the same
time I haven't but anyway you're bad
[__] to get to get don't forget
Pittsburgh improv just weekend Saturday
Late Show sold out already so you got
four to choose from right now maybe even
[__] three so get your tickets now
get the party started Thursday night why
not yeah I'm saying show up with a
permit the brothers sandwich and we'll
[__] put it together here my brother
Felipe Esparza just walked in this
[__] so it's that time I'm
saying once the fool or something you be
my son that's how we do it this is not
goes all over again this is not ghost
season four right here for brother
throws Chaplin where the Cuban meets the
Mexican it's all over but the shot
I play Carter Quintero the leader the
horrible one whatever whatever the [__]
don't worry about the cartel just pay
attention [__]
you're in for a [__] big night
tonight Lee you driving again let's do a
lift
look at you sit down relax one of these
silver misunderstanding
hoping you don't leave the door okay
somebody finds Lee's been known to fart
when he doesn't bunt him you ready for
Bonnie Lee
oh yeah you can take one of those it's
these are 200 apiece what the [__] you
think you're dealing with you tuned in
to a good night [__] LeMay
supports the Jews the Costa Coffee you
learn something new every day if you
want to run with Jews you gotta have the
coffee babe
oh [__] Jimmy Page just drop it
[Music]
the farm
oh [__]
stay right there dog there it is right
there doggie dog that's the one that's
the one all the way all the way all the
way who gives a [__] there you go like a
doctor oh [__] practice makes perfect
yeah we're [__] around it we got
bonds of all sizes we got the little
mule the medium meal and the big one is
Godzilla Japanese people don't come in
here because well back you filthy
[__] animals you wanna smoke some
weed Philippe it won't do it you got one
now you don't want to Godzilla you're
ready from you all for this
and you can't be a wife and you my
little watch Dancing with the Stars
[Music]
ready dumb
you want to test the wo Joey's coming to
[__] now hey go dog yo
[Music]
are you kidding me a lot and you want to
do this and do that what you want you
want to be right here with uncle Joey
and set last oh well they'll say my zero
there for the [__] spelling it oh [__]
since I first set eyes on you
Here I am alone and blue
[Music]
using our culture
one of the bondage oh [__] yeah people
talking all about by the way you left
this place
I don't care what the people say I know
where their job is that
[Music]
first time I heard this guy seriously I
was drug free and this is one of the
reasons I did [__] drugs this [__]
song for years we've like the [__]
the gourmet Club when I ended up at
pollutes house God rest his soul are you
kidding me
are you [__] kidding me once I heard
this we said four beers we showed up
with sophomores we came back with a case
of nips and they just shook their
[__] heads and all the teachers left
once I heard this it was all over the
shop this out was the worst that ever
could happen to me cuz it took me to the
other [__] inside and let me know that
whatever the [__] you were thinking
about it what I'm funky were doing it
didn't matter listen to this [__] come
on you're gonna come at me with some
story about your day and [__]
Starbucks get it together ready don't
for Freddie what's up dog you're going
through changes please already gone
through changes over there
[Music]
whoa Lord O Lord
dirty explosive you will listen to your
heart was [__] beatin you thought you
were doing something bad you're 12 years
old what am i doing I'm sitting in a
[__] room but you listen to this [__]
what what what
I gotta care about religion therefore
this how you gonna care about the
government after this how you gonna give
a [__]
listen for this [__]
this is it once I heard this I went to
the other side I didn't give a [__]
about both things anymore
listen to this this is the other [__]
side mentally understand me
if you don't [__] it go to [__] bong
gets listen to this [__] the dark you
ain't gonna see the other side I ain't
gotta get the answers that you [__]
looking for
[Music]
oh that's all hard a can of wine get
some money saying are you [__] nuts
break up the [__] China white book on
into the murky waters tonight
somebody's drool on their shirt today
[Music]
rape another pocket Lila Rouge let's do
it bring that thing with a purple number
here we go
[Laughter]
living loving she says that warm are you
[__] nuts
let's give leaves some [__] monster
cookies oh [__] I know you like a second
that's your middle name cookies cookie
boy cookies who's better than you
[__] y'all be in the Voodoo
Lounge smoking reefer yong-chol Joey
you're not getting molested everything's
good you looking up you're not getting
molested finally hey yo we uncle Joey
finally
[Music]
I'm the only uncle don't molest you
sexually mentally I [__] you up that
don't matter
[Music]
oh [__] that's the one link that's the
one ticket take that [__] that's
the one right there
that's the one that killed charlie you
asking me it was Charlie don't worry
about Charlie
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about
shut up I'm saying what you do with the
knowledge is up to you [__] you
this is the week that killed the whole
[__] organization
you think I'm [__] with you can I'm
gonna show up here with a gun with three
bullets are you [__] killing me
trying to help I'm saying but anyway
here you do knock on it /c / Joey Diaz
is the place to be [__] you
know I love you forget what's on
delaying dick on TV rhetoric North
Koreans people kneeling down who gives a
bump it's time to get together we uncle
Joey listen to a chitchat youtube.com
slash c / Joey Diaz and don't forget
Saturday night with time Philippe my
brother Philippe baseball's first ever
HBO specials coming right to your living
room if you don't watch it and you got
HBO I'm gonna talk to you no more yeah
man you watch it if you don't watch it
[__] you no more you understand we've
done the same this is a family you gotta
support when you get your HBO special
I'll [__] watch it alright don't
forget take it still available for
Thursday and Friday night at the
Pittsburgh improv I'll be on the radio
tomorrow morning for you [__] burgers
you know I love you mother [__] I see
it a little while youtube.com slash c /
Joey Diaz that's where you need to be
kind of sickness I love you